au départ c'est uniquement pour sa fille
qu'il écrivit l'histoire d'emilie jolie
un joli conte musical qui sera un
triomphe
près de deux millions et demi d'albums
vendus et trois mille adaptation dans le
monde
la comédie musicale traverse les
générations et fête aujourd'hui ses 30
ans pour le plus grand bonheur des
enfants et de son créateur voici
maintenant l'invité des cinq dernières
minutes et s'est invitée c'est philippe
chatel bonjour et merci d'être avec nous
sur ce plateau du 13 heures en écrivant
il ya trente ans ces histoires magiques
pour votre fille est ce que vous auriez
pu imaginer un tel succès c'est sûr que
non j'ai fait ça pour m'amuser et pour
amuser ma fille et c'est vrai en fait
c'est le public qui fait le succès c'est
pas on travaille autant pour un échec
que pour un succès après c'est le public
qui décide et qui choisit et là il a
décidé que depuis 30 ans bah ça lui
plairait et c'est un grand bonheur quoi
c'est un vrai bonheur ça c'est sûr en
l'écoutant encore aujourd'hui comment
peut-on expliquer qu emilie jolie
traverse les générations aussi
facilement parce que je pense que
d'abord c'est pas fixer dans le temps
c'est pas une histoire qui qui est fixé
dans un temps précis par exemple je sais
pas sous louis xiv ou pendant les années
50 c'était hors du temps voilà et c'est
surtout des je pense des sujets qu'ils
sont
intemporels comme la peur comme le
le goût du bonheur le goût du rêve et c
est ce assez
c'est au oui ça se démode pas si c'est
parce que c'est pas la mode que ça m'a
choqué ça marche encore alors la comédie
musicale continue d'être joué sur les
plus grandes scènes internationales
hélas pour ses 30 ans l'édition
originale ressort c'est une version qui
est remixé et remasteriser c'est à dire
c'est la même version qu'à l'époque
simplement techniquement le son est bien
meilleure je m'engage pas dire à mon âge
aidant dussault patrice coumes parce que
c'est lui qui fait le boulot mais il
faut pas que les gens se méprennent
c'est le même disque est donc sauf que
le son est mieux le son est mieux et on
retrouve les grandes voix
on n'a pas tous les citer alain souchon
sylvie vartan julien quesne soit georges
brassens
comment avez vous fait pour les
convaincre à l'époque qu'est ce qui vous
en dis tout de suite oui
écoutez en deux mots quand j'ai fini
d'écrire je me suis fait sur un bout de
papier un casting idéal en disant tiens
ça serait bien de brassens reste le
hérisson joli casting julien clerc phase
3 odst à et se trouve je les ai j'aurais
téléphoné il faut dire qu'à l'époque le
le métier plus artisanal qu'aujourd'hui
je leur ai téléphoné m'ont tous dit oui
à chacun d'entre eux j'ai joué
l'ensemble de l'histoire avec toutes les
chansons j'y vois là je voudrais que
touchant de celle là et m'ont tous dit
oui c'était très simple en fait ils vous
ont tous fait un très beau cadeau et me
joly c'est vraiment votre plus gros
succès on peut le dire est ce que cette
oeuvre magistrale n'a pas pris un peu
trop de place dans votre carrière
peut-être vous savez on bon on porte
toujours la casquette de de son plus
grand succès c'est vrai que si on prend
à nous notre exemple que moi romy
schneider
pour les gens c'est d'abord 6,6 alors
qu'elle a fait des tas de films
extraordinaires comme la piscine comme
les fumées claude claude sautet etc
mais pour les gens elle restera quelque
part si si et c'est vrai que c'est un
peu dommage parce que elle a fait une
carrière extraordinaire
elle a joué dans les très très très
grands films des chefs-d'oeuvre du
cinéma qui resteront mais c'est vrai
qu'elle porte cette casquette là bon il
vaut mieux avoir une casquette coup pas
de casquette
juste une dernière question avant de
vous entendre chanter on peut vous
demander quel âge à la vraie emilie
jolie de votre boss maintenant à la 33
ans à l'époque et les trois ans c'est
pas elle qui chante et 1 mais elle avait
donc trois ans voilà trente trois ans
donc aujourd'hui je vous laisse vous
installez vous écouter chanter vous
allez nous interpréter un extrait de
votre comédie musicale le duo d'emilie
jolie avec le grand oiseau que tout le
monde connaît évidemment grand oiseau
qui était chantée par julien clerc
[Musique]
et
tu appelles ml jours
ta belle emilie
voudraient partir avec tous
[Musique]
tout au goût du ciel sur noël et tu
voudrais vivre avec
ta vie
[Musique]
tu appelles emilie jolie
tu rêves de vol est parti rejoindre le
soleil et même la lune sur nos plus
faire un petit tour
au paradis
oui c'est ça vous m'avez compris alors
dites - oui
[Musique]
mais ya tant de choses à voir avant
de partir pour le firmament
ya tant de pages à tourner la vie ne
fait de pons
bientôt on ne parle jamais
partir pour le firmament
il ya dans le jour et dans le nuit
tueuse ou des rues de ta vie
le ta vie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup je rappelle que l'édition
originale remixé remastérisée sort à
l'occasion des 30 ans d'emilie jolie
avec un cadeau en prime un
enregistrement de l'époque de georges
brassens qui joue le rôle du hérisson
dans le compte
[Musique]